foreign
and welcome to today's webinar
eavesdropping on biological processes
with multi-model and Multiplex Imaging
I'm Susie Valdez of Labyrinth and I will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Leica Microsystems to learn more
visit them at Leica hyphen
microsystems.com now we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of this
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation I'd now like to welcome our
speaker Dr Scott Fraser from Elizabeth
Garrett chair in convergent biosciences
he's the Provost and professor of
biology and biomedical engineering and
the director of science initiatives at
University of Southern California
Scott welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
well thank you very much for that kind
introduction and for having me here
today to tell you about our work
using Imaging to watch biological
processes as they're taking place in
systems as diverse as I'm showing here a
lymph node where we're watching cells
from the outside coming into the lymph
node and communicating and beating heart
on the far right
I've been very active in trying to
develop interdisciplinary tools and in
translating them out into the
marketplace so I have a huge disclosures
to make
and what I'm going to try to tell you
about today is the work that we've been
doing working on
embryos as a system that allows us to do
analyzes of cells in their normal
setting
why we like embryos is that they
exercise a good fraction of their genome
quickly enough in a small enough package
that we can use Imaging to an advantage
now many of the studies right now and
most of the systems analysis studies uh
involve single cell techniques and these
single cell techniques have been
incredibly powerful for discovering
proteins and discovering the genes that
code for those proteins but they haven't
been as good as keeping the cells in
their normal setting and capturing what
the Dynamics are of the cells
interacting with one another they have
shown a great bit of heterogeneity and
variability and that's often a
complication
what we're trying to do is to use
Imaging to move those systems analyzes
into embodied cells as we'd like to say
this way we are looking at the cells in
their normal setting and the Dynamics
and the variance isn't something for us
to curse at instead that Dynamics and
that variance is the signal that we're
using to understand the underlying
processes but of course that requires
the sort of Multiplex and multimodal
tools that I'm going to talk about today
I'm going to start by just mentioning
the tools we've been using for looking
in fixed preparations these fixed
preparations we would like to be able to
understand where genes are expressed and
so to be able to do that in a
quantitative fashion and being able to
look at multiple uh Target rnas we've
gone over to an approach called
hybridization Chain Reaction developed
together with our colleagues in at
Caltech at the time Niles Pierce and his
laboratory
this technology depends on hairpins that
are happy in solution interacting with
themselves as you can see in this simple
cartoon of a hairpin
even though they would like to bind to
one another they're trapped in that
state by all the base pairing across the
stem and so they are trapped in that
metastable state until they see an
initiator sequence that initiator
sequence I've got a star here Mark is
complementary to the a of one of the toe
holds and when it binds now it can open
up this hairpin by Branch migration
because it has a sequence that will
complement the uh The Hairpin sequence
and open it up that exposed the sea star
V Star which happens to be the initiator
for the other hairpin and so this goes
on and on regenerating the initial
initiator and growing explosively
because this relies on sequence uh
identity between the initiator and The
Hairpin this can be done in a multiplex
fashion and so if we take four different
hairpin pairs labeled with distinct dies
we can see that these hair pins on a gel
will run to the small molecular low
domain here in the gel in the presence
of just blender extract of tissue or any
other sort of non-specific sequences
being added but if we had initiator for
say hairpin pair one the blue appears as
a 200 mer so of hairpins and disappears
from the small hair pins that are
individual instead if I add initiator 3
the green appears and disappears from
Below
now this can be turned into a way to
look at
the distribution of rnas in a tissue by
using antisense probes to recognize the
RNA then initiator sequences of flanking
those and when hairpins wrath added then
they self-assemble and each place that
there's an initiator we get about 200
dies being deposited that's enough for
us to see deep within tissue and the
reagents are small enough to penetrate
well so it gives us a very reliable gain
that's very linear
and it allows us to see fine features
unlike for example in the right you can
see a conventional in C2 hybridization
you can see the conventional and C2
hybridization in this case looked at uh
with uh fluorescence and if we look
Instead at the HCR you can see that even
the nascent transcripts within the
nucleus these dots show up clearly as
well as the localization of RNA within
the cell
because it's got such good capture
efficiency and such good linearity we
can even detect the same message in more
than one color and this allows us to
validate both the efficiency and the
linearity of the gain in this case I'm
detecting the same RNA with red and
green hairpins you can see the two
images here and if we plot it on a pixel
by pixel basis you can see that they are
clearly greater than the background
signal and the nice clustered linear
plot shows us that we've got good linear
gain and a good discrimination ability
signal from noise
this approach of course brings up one of
the problems that we have whenever we're
using Imaging and that problem is that
we're always trying to compromise
between opposed goals we would like to
be able to image at infinite resolution
infinitely quickly and throughout the
depth of a specimen
and we're often frustrated by the fact
that as we try to get a higher
resolution that typically sacrifices
speed and depth and and so on and
lurking in the background is the
enabling a photon budget how many
photons are there being given off per
pixel per unit time
to try to make this frustration less
frustrating we've gone over to a
slightly improved version which we're
calling Muse that allows us to
conveniently get a larger gain and also
to use distinct labels for different uh
Imaging modalities
just like before this relies on an
initiator sequence and here I've
cartooned it differently is these
Chevrons the Chevrons give us the same
uh sequence specific orthogonal
gain and we can then later put on dyes
or metals that allow us to see this
within a cytop instrument and it sends
this initiator can go on to proteins
like ligands that bind to other proteins
or antibodies or onto rnas we can easily
go into tissue and see the protein and
see the RNA
we're excited about it because it allows
us to use labels that are inconvenient
in most preparations like Quantum dots
and pick up both the spectral advantages
of quantum dots or other sort of dot
like structures uh that can be a couple
of orders of magnitude more Photon
budget
it also gives us a greater gain you can
see that if we run just our standard
Muse or our higher gain use we can pick
up one or two orders of magnitude and
intensity and we can also see proteins
and in this case we're looking at fly
embryos which we find to be a very
convenient system to test our
developments
because we can put these initiators on
antibodies and those antibodies can be
directly labeled for example rabbit
primary antibodies we can do four Plex
uh recognition using no secondary
antibodies and using antibodies all from
the same species in this case all
primary antibodies from Rabbits we can
look at rnas and you can see the
individual dots and if I was to blow
these up you would see that they are
nicely orthogonal none of the dots are
double labeled
and we can also of course do uh
simultaneous immunofluorescence or other
ligand binding studies with the RNA
studies
so this technique has really allowed us
to go into settings and ask where genes
are expressed and allowed us to test the
results of single cell studies that have
been performed uh looking at the
proteome or the transcriptome
well it allows us to see those and
allows us to see many of them in context
the bad news is that there's five
gigavoxels worth of Imaging data here
and in a conventional confocal
microscope that can be a significant
amount of time and we typically have to
do tiled acquisition so this is four by
six image stacks and you can see the
slight bit of bleaching at the borders
because it was imaged twice
so we are of course wanting to get rid
of this bad noise I'll tell you a little
bit about that the other bad news is
we'd like to be doing more than three or
four colors and I'll spend the balance
of my time talking about that
so because biological imaging has no
free lunch we always live in this uh
pyramid of frustration one thing we're
wondering is about the you know sort of
minimizing the cost of that lunch and
one way to minimize the cost of that
lunch is to move from point scanning
microscopy a confocal or a two Photon
microscope to light sheet microscopy
where we bring in a light sheet from the
side to do the excitation of the
fluorochrome and collect the image in
parallel
this allows us to benefit from the
Moore's Law sort of development in the
capabilities of cameras that can acquire
a low noise image very rapidly of a
whole image plane
to get deeper Imaging and in lower
phototoxicity we've gone over from the
normal blue light excitation as you're
seeing here which uh over here to the
right you can see a laser beam moving
across the side you can see in this
slightly scattering media the labeled
beads in this case within gel uh showing
up but you can see that there's a finite
width to This Light sheet and it tapers
to a minimum thickness at its uh at its
focus but any light scattering can give
us some excitation outside of the focal
plane two Photon requires on this the
simultaneous absorption of two infrared
photons and because of that we get no
excitation when the light's not uh
focused down in that Central focal
region you can see we get a very nice
clean uh light a sheet excitation domain
with a distinct start and stop and this
allows us to go deeper into the
preparation without seeing blurring from
scattering and it also allows us to see
very Dynamic things without any sign of
phototoxicity
this is a fly embryo again watching it
develop on the stage of the microscope
and fly embryos developed on the stage
the microscope but not in the beam or
just out on the lab bench are at exactly
the same pace and eventually hatch the
same way
because it's infrared light it also
allows us to go deep into structures
that might otherwise respond delayed in
this case we're looking at the calcium
signal from a light sheet recording of a
zebrafish you can see him here in being
held within the field of view of the
microscope and what I hope you can see
is the individual
bright spots as there's activity in the
brain using calcium level as the
surrogate for looking at the neuronal
activity and we can see throughout the
depth of the brain this is part of a two
day long time lapse movie without
appreciable photo bleaching which really
shows the power of two Photon light
sheets
that two Photon light sheet lets us move
from hours to minutes for our Imaging
lets us capture Dynamic structures like
this beating embryonic heart that you're
seeing to the right and even let's just
see at subcellular resolution for
example you can see the individual cells
of the cardiomyocytes here
as the heart is feeding
so back to our question of no free lunch
I've just told you about ways that we
can increase the photon budget I've told
you about ways that we can increase the
speed and depth by going to two Photon
light sheet what about increasing the
multiplexing I want to look at many
different labels at one time and if I
want to look at those many labels at one
time I need some way of carrying more
colors into the situation and I'd like
to do it with a real-time sort of
processing
and this problem anything having to do
with fluorochromes and trying to look at
more colors is always plagued by the
problem of looking at a spectrum that is
finite in its width in fact it's wider
than the difference between a yellow
fluorescent protein than a green
fluorescent protein
so the cartoon above shows what we hope
to see if we look at it in true color
the blood vessels and the muscle cells
are not that distinguishable by eye
on a normal confocal microscope we are a
light sheet microscope where we've got
multiple fluorescent proteins like blue
fluorescent protein green yellow and
some of the red fluorescent proteins and
of course some of the background
autofluorescence you can see what the
challenge is because many of these
Spectra overlap considerably and our
temptation is always to use narrower and
narrower more selective filters to try
to see that signal but as you can see
even if I make a narrow uh
detection filter there's still a
significant amount of yellow fluorescent
protein coming through in the green
fluorescent protein signal and even if I
went down to a very very small window
I'd still have other things bleeding
through and of course I'd be throwing
away most of my photons and so I'd be
hurting myself on the Pyramid of
frustration
years ago we began trying to deal with
this instead of with narrower band pass
filters using approaches that were
borrowed from the remote sensing crowd
the people that fly satellites over the
Earth for example in which they collect
a spectral Cube that's like an image
stack but it's a spectral stack or a
Lambda stack
so x y and wavelength we built
microscopes that could uh see multiple
wavelengths for example by using a
grading and a multi-window PMT and even
commercial units have been able to
execute this uh this showing the Zeiss
unit for doing multi-spectral detection
the approach is very simple it's
normally it uses a approach called
linear and mixing where knowing the
basis Spectra and a number of spectral
bands collected at once you can see that
gfp and fluorescein overlap in every one
of these spectral bands but knowing what
those basis spectrum is it's possible to
unmix the two
now this has the advantage that it lets
us see dies that are very much
overlapping in their Spectra is distinct
but it involves a significant processing
time and it also involves the problem
that the noise of the least bright label
gets imposed on the brighter labels and
you might be able to see the photon
counting noise of the green label being
imposed on the red label in this
unmixing
luckily an approach from Enrico Graton
and his colleagues of using the phaser a
Fourier transform of the spectrum gives
us a way to speed the processing and
improve the performance
in this approach a region that's read
here and would have this Red Spectrum
when we take the Fourier transform and
plot the real and imaginary terms of one
of the harmonics of upgrade transform in
what he calls the phaser plot we've got
here a red dot for that Red Spectrum the
green Spectrum give becomes a Green Dot
in a 50 50 mix instead of being as
double hump thing that we have to try to
do linear on mixing on becomes a DOT
halfway in between a 70 30 mix or a
30-70 mix is positioned in between the
two just as you'd guess from the ratios
this has allowed us to do hyperspectral
phaser on the same Imaging data trying
to separate it out optically
separating out by linear unmixing where
you can see the photon counting noise
being imposed in the other channels and
where the five gig of voxels of data can
take some time to process it in many
settings and the hyperspectral phaser
which can be far less than a second of
processing in fact more on the
millisecond scale
this allows us to cleanly see the blood
vessels and the muscle cells as two
seconds separate structures and it lets
us look for example in this animation at
several different fluorescent proteins
in the same living specimen
foreign
though the Spectra overlap considerably
we can separate the signals nicely and
even collect the signals using non-ideal
excitation wavelengths for example
we use two different excitation lasers
in this case one at 458 which is not
what you'd normally choose for gfp or
citrine but it allows us to use the
unmixing very actively to get our
different signals
we've been using a combination or what
we call hybrid unmexing as a way to
capture that speed and that ability to
do multiplexing and this cartoon helps
us understand why it works our normal
hyperspectral uh data set of something
like a zebrafish embryo
would involve us doing linear on mixing
on each of the pixels or each of the
voxels excuse me within this specimen
which can be tens of millions if not
more different things and so that takes
some time
if we instead reduce this into the
hyperspectral phaser world and do some
spectral denoising we can change or we
can process the Spectra without
degrading the spatial resolution we can
bend this on the spectral phasor diagram
and then do the uh the unmixing now on
each one of these pixels and use that to
try to do the same sort of unmixing but
now on far fewer pixels so we can more
work far far faster and get much cleaner
lower noise results
now if we want to carry that to an
extreme and and that accounts by the way
for the very fast processing time that
we can get good performance
but now what we really want to do is go
uh in that pyramid of frustration tell
you it's the lowest number of photons
being collected the fewest excitation
events and as we do that these nice
Spectra become noisy because of the
photon counting that happens as we have
fewer and fewer photons
we have used machine learning to try to
reconstruct the Spectra using the noisy
Photon star Spectra and the known
Spectra to try to predict what was there
and see if we can get a an approach that
lets us reconstruct the Spectra at
minimal light doses
this means we have to do a huge training
set and while we could do this by
collecting ground truth images and the
low signal images we can also do it by
building and validating a very good
model of a microscope and using that to
generate
spectral data sets at loan low signal
and at low noise and training the
machine learning algorithm
this approach has allowed us to generate
very useful data for example of cell
boundaries and structures in the
perinuclear space which are largely
obscured as we go to low noise Imaging
or low Photon Imaging Sorry by the noise
that's there
and it allows us now to collect images
with far fewer photons than ever before
and with far greater dynamic range than
ever before so we can look at the signal
in the presence of background noise and
autofluorescence and in that same image
even separate out the different
contributions from cell types that auto
fluoresce like the xanthophores labels
that are within the cells like the
retinoids or the metabolic signatures
like nadh free inbound that we can use
to try to see the metabolism of the
individual cells
so this hybrid of mixing approach has
allowed us to go in and see things that
normally we would be just just invisible
from our site because the specimen is so
light sensitive
now we're very interested in applying
this to settings that are not like this
uh this
zebrafish where we've got multiple
fluorescent proteins for example in
patient specimens very few patient
specimens come in with gfp and other
fluorescent protein level labels and
what you can see is using the spectral
signal we can separate out metabolic
signals intrinsic labels that are
biological signaling important
importance and of course other metabolic
sort of signatures that are around
but to try to get these signals what
we're trying to do now is to go away
from just spectral signals and see if we
can move to Lifetime Imaging to get a
far more reliable way of seeing things
this approach relies not on looking at
the wavelength of the emitted light but
the time delay between the excitation
and the emission which would normally be
an exponential and we can do this at
relatively low Photon counts by
collecting multiple periods and Counting
the individual photons reconstructing
that exponential after a laser pulse
the power of this is that you can unmix
the different components and in this
multi-exponential Decay that's happening
identify the different components just
as we are doing with the linear unmixing
that is doable but painful and luckily
Enrico Graton uh developed his phasor
approach for looking at lifetime data in
which it allows us again to plot the
lifetime of things by taking the the
Fourier transform and to unmix the
amount of different components by
looking at the geometry of the signal in
between two
so this approach that's been developed
and really formalized at UC Irvine
within the laboratory for fluorescence
Dynamics really offers us a way to take
those multi-exponentials and put them
onto this Universal Circle in which we
can see very short to very long
lifetimes and any combination of the
multiple labels that are there will be
found at some position in between them
for example if we look at cell
metabolism free nadh versus bound nadh
that is a free in solution in the cell
which happens to be the way that cells
are when they're in glycolysis nadh is
bound to enzyme and cells that are
undergoing oxidative phosphorylation so
they have slower lifetimes and you can
see that those depending on the enzyme
get moved over here to the left
so that means that there's a convenient
way to follow using the phaser and using
the unmixing that we can do on the
phaser plot the background
autofluorescence from the metabolic
signal and see something as simple as
cells being fed here going from one
metabolic state to another when fresh
medium is added to the plate
it also means that we can use metabolism
to look into unlabeled structures and
this again is from the Enrico Graton and
colleagues work looking at intact
intestines and looking for the metabolic
signature that's present in the stem
cells within that what they're able to
show is that stem cells and different
transient progenitors have different
lifetimes different positions on this
um this phaser plot that allows them to
Cluster them
now all of this is doable and we've had
equipment that we've built at home or
purchase that can do this sort of
Imaging but it has not been easy and
it's been a challenge to train users
this got much easier recently with uh
Leica embracing lifetime Imaging and
we've been able now to train uh
clinicians clinical scientists
undergrads high school students into a
metabolic Imaging now and this just
shows one image or one set of images
collected with the Leica instrument that
makes it far easier to analyze here
using phaser to follow as the yellow
signature that's present in the side
population or some people might even
call them cancer stem cell State as it's
lost over time the same cell becoming a
non-side population or non-stem cell
State over the course of a day
this technology has allowed us to look
at systems we've never thought we'd be
able to before and we've been able to
collect images and actually well train
users and have users train other users
so it's been quite an improvement
so what about inspectral phaser uh
Imaging can we get a similar Advance
there and just recently there's been a
similar uh effort in making friendly
approaches or doing multi-spectral
Imaging you can see here a rendering I
sort of cutaway view of a multi-spectral
detector inside of the new Leica Mika
we have been using and training users on
this microscope now and what we like
about it is within a single exposure it
can collect images in wide field or in
confocal mode
because the specimen is held inside of
this dark enclosure it's possible for us
to sit this in the lab with its support
electronics and its incubation and
everything else underneath so that we
can collect these images in a normal
setting rather than in a dark room and
again this is a technique that's allowed
or a tool I should say that's allowing
people to train one another in this
powerful technique of some of
hyperspectral phasor Imaging
so I'm going to end there and talk and
just sort of summarize quickly how we've
tried to add Dimensions to Imaging I've
told you a little bit about Multiplex
Imaging of rnas and our approach to try
to add Dimensions by adding spectral
phasor analysis or Flynn analysis
I hope I've given you a little taste of
the idea of
um of using these approaches to try to
look into specimens that are very
challenging and I'll just sort of end
with two teasers that are shown here in
the in the lower right you can see a
beating heart where we're looking at
both the blood cells inside and The
myocardium and following them in 3D and
watching a an active brain in this case
of a zebrafish larva as as it's
responding individual of cues what we're
hoping is that these approaches with
these new more friendly tools are going
to let us really go after the things
that we thought were impossible or at
least impractical like watching memories
form within an intact animal
and I'm going to end by thanking the
teams the people that have made each of
these tools possible the two that I just
hinted about are shown over here to the
right but the people that really made
each of these tools work and sing are
shown here to the to the left side of
the slide and of course we owe a huge uh
debt to them and to the funding agencies
that have made this all possible
so thank you for your attention and I'd
be really happy to take any questions
that you might have on this work
foreign
and thank you Scott for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of this webinar if you have
any questions you want to ask please do
so now just click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
get started looks like we already have
some great questions coming in Scott our
first question you say lifetime is under
used why has it been so underused
foreign
requires special instrumentation to be
able to acquire it but it also requires
people to think the way they think about
the way they acquire the images they
have to be able to not just see what
wavelength of spectrum of the emitted
fluorochrome is but how long after the
pulse of a laser light for example the
emission is taking place
this equipment has not always been a
very user friendly and uh it's also uh
equipment that is less commonly
available
uh why we're excited about it is now
that we have equipment that's more user
friendly uh we're finding that the users
are recruiting other users and in fact
the users are training other users in uh
collecting the data and that's sort of a
newfound thing for us I think I might
have mentioned that during the talk that
previously the work was was doable but
painful and it's now quite a bit less
painful and quite a bit more robust with
uh with the Falcon microscope that we've
been using from Leica
thank you so much our next audience
member wants to know how do you train
people in these Cutting Edge tools
well so that's an interesting Challenge
and one of the things that's been nice
about Enrico Burton's formalism of using
the phaser is I think it's much easier
to get an intuitive feel for how the
processing is going on and also be able
to interrogate the data in a in a way
one of our researchers from chesco
coutrale talks about it almost as
ping-ponging between the phaser display
and the real image display and being
able to go around and discover different
features in different regions within the
tissue
so the training has become a lot more
intuitive and the equipment has gotten
uh much more integrated in being able to
do that some of our early
instrumentation required one computer to
run the microscope another to run the
analyzes and those sort of offline or
running in parallel approaches have been
much more of a challenge because while
they're collecting they have to imagine
what the result might be uh then then
the integrated tools that we have now
with the with the Mika for example
thank you so much now how do you
Benchmark or validate the findings
you know in imaging this is one of our
big challenges and one that I think we
really face as a field uh how do we move
from a picture to knowing that where
that picture is capturing something uh
valid we have been doing that by trying
to collect uh images with different
numbers of labels or different numbers
of photons and looking at the errors
that result as we go to minimal dose
Imaging it's something I think that's
going to be a challenge for all of us
and I think we're going to have to
really Embrace is think about how do we
know that the nice picture we're getting
is the picture that actually has the
meaningful data in it I think some of
these recent tools are making it easier
to do that because the answers are more
quantitative and easier to interrogate
but I think it's going to remain a
challenge for the whole field for a
while especially as we're thinking about
reproducibility of the findings and so
on
thank you so much Scott and I want to
thank our audience for these great
questions that are coming in
Scott can these tools become routine
enough that pipelines can be created
well that is what we hope for and in
fact that's what we think we're
establishing right now for some of our
collaborators uh by pipelines what what
well I I will put words in the person's
mouth but I will turn it into a question
I can answer by a pipeline what I'm
thinking about is some sort of protocol
I can give people for the collection the
processing and even the figure rendering
of the data and together with Carl
kesselman and a number of colleagues
within the translational Imaging Center
at USC we've been trying to build an
environment in which the figure Legend
gives people a DOI that links them to
the data collection pipeline to the raw
data and to the tools we're hoping that
that sort of pipeline will help us in
interrogating and reinterrogating the
same data and also in distributing that
as a pipeline if others want to collect
similar data they can look at that
digital object identifier and be able to
find the tools and the pipeline and all
the details that normally you might have
to go through six or eight papers to
find because people always refer to
another paper that they did some other
aspect with it so we're we're excited
about the possibility not only of
creating these pipelines but making them
facile for others to use and and we're
hoping even to provide some of these
through uh NIH grant that we're uh just
waiting to hear word on because we would
like to be able to provide this to the
field in general uh ways to get at
answers in some of these molecular
Imaging questions
absolutely now our next audience member
asks is there a theoretical and
practical limit to how many spectral
contributors can be separated
yes it's a moving standard uh many
people think for example that if you
collect three spectral bins that you can
separate three labels and I would argue
that's not the case once we move into
the phaser space we can see in our data
and Enrico gratons and many of the
others that have used this sort of
approach that uh small differences can
be captured that are very predictive of
labels we can also see cases when the
Discrimination fails and cases in which
the photons are too few photons to make
a reliable uh call
so I think in all of these cases there's
no
um theoretical limit but there's a clear
practical limit and what we try to do is
drop our Photon budget by a few fold and
see if we can still make the
Discrimination this is why we did the
machine learning tools in part is to see
what we Could reconstruct from that but
to understand the failure modes and I
think it's going to be incumbent on all
of us not just to blindly assume if I'm
collecting four channels I can do four
labels or if I'm collecting 10 I can do
10 labels I would argue that that's not
the case instead we have to really
validate in our setting where the
indeterminacies happen
thank you so much I I also noticed that
uh somebody asked a question about how
small the differences can be and that
how small the differences can be can be
very very subtle for example a few years
ago we did an analysis with five
different green dyes doing a
multi-spectral multi-label separation
and it looked as good as many of the RGB
uh and far red eye separations we had
done on other equipment so I think that
there's no hard and fast rules about the
number of labels and the number of bins
thank you so much and to add to that
question that you were just answering
that same audience member said like 0.5
NS and just the follow-up question how
many oh okay on Lifetime and how how
many cells or experiments do you usually
carry to make sure the differences is
indeed there
yes so uh the difference in lifetime
that we can see uh depends partially on
the photon budget so how many photons do
you collect to make sure that you are
resolving the the lifetime difference a
half of an nanosecond is more than
enough to see uh major changes uh in uh
with with enough photons being collected
that typically slows down the experiment
a little bit although with the Falcon
approach it's been less of a sacrifice
we've had a much better efficiency in
collecting enough photons
um
it's important in uh lifetime Imaging
just as in single cell sequencing or any
other sort of uh thing where we're
looking at discrete differences between
cells or between voxels to do the
statistics carefully and one of our
challenges is to make sure that our
users are collecting enough cells and
enough pixels within the cells to really
trust the results and run statistical
tests to to validate it we've not had a
problem and so far none of the issues
we've looked at as we've collected more
and more data have we had to revise what
we thought in our earlier analysis so
like with anything I think it's just
using good statistics is is key
thank you so much Scott and again I want
to thank our audience we have time for a
few more questions
Scott when you say fees are inside and
spectral phaser inside does this mean I
need to train people on how to use and
read the vager plot to be able to use
that system
yeah you know I I was a little bit
worried when I wrote that there it was I
put it on the slide in part because I
used to have a laptop computer that had
Intel Inside written on it and
um I I I liked that phrase uh in the
case of my laptop I didn't need to know
how to use a mask aligner and how to uh
to do the lithography on a computer chip
or even how to write a lower level code
that would run it to be able to exploit
that Intel that was inside and and one
of the things that I've really liked
about the phaser approaches and the Mika
implementation in particular is uh you
don't have to be able to think in phaser
space to be able to use it any more than
I needed to be a material scientist to
be able to use an Intel microprocessor I
so it's it's to the user it's the
underlying machine that makes the
separations possible and
um and that separation is seamless and
fast enough that you're not even aware
it's going on in the same way that you
don't think about the cycles of the
clock in your in your processor in your
laptop
so uh I didn't mean to put it in like it
was some of our earlier equipment that
we've designed that to run required two
physicists lurking over your shoulders
to adjust the mirrors and and tweak
things while you are collecting data
this is almost the opposite uh this
microscope
um sort of runs like the iPhone of of
the microscope world and
um I've just been amazed at the number
of users that have been trained by other
users and how to use it uh just the same
as if I want to know how to use my
iPhone I have to add my ask my kids or
nephews uh about about the features
because without looking at the manual
they can intuitively work through a lot
of the of the details
thank you now how are you planning to
use spectral or lifetime fees or on SP
IM configuration film cameras are
typically slow and poor in futon Budget
on the other hand spectral cameras are
expensive do you have some suggestions
about this
well that's a great question and one of
the challenges has been uh that each of
these approaches is has a has had a real
cost
so the typical hyperspectral camera or
hyperspectral detector
sacrifices the majority of the light and
it hurts your Photon budget in order to
get the spectral or the lifetime uh
separation
in lifetime phaser has been dramatically
more efficient with the photons than uh
than some of the time uh correlated
approaches some of the photon accounting
approaches that are typically employed
and it's why Enrico Graton has been so
successful and why we've enjoyed
borrowing heavily from his work
in the hyperspectral phaser Francesco
cottrelle has really changed
dramatically what we're able to do in
hyperspectral detection and he and his
colleagues have really may have recently
made a wide field camera
that even taking into account the
efficiency of the detector is
approaching 90 percent efficiency on the
detection and the spectral distinction
of the labels this is dramatically
different than the situation with many
of the hyperspectral cameras that are
out there that have enviable performance
but get that performance by throwing
away you know 95 of the photons uh and I
shouldn't say throwing away the cost of
its implementation is the majority of
photons and it can be as high as 95 are
are lost
so uh we're very excited and are now
working in our light sheet Imaging in
implementing that design that designs
also uh very fast and very inexpensive
and so we're hoping that it or the next
generation of tools that are developed
by Francesco and his colleagues will
give us the ability to do hyper spectral
detection without the conventional cost
that I'm sure the questioner was
thinking about uh and many of the
cameras that we in the past have tried
to use or some of the laser Technologies
we've tried to use have just involved
putting too many photons onto the
specimen and uh and perturb the very
thing we're hoping to study
thank you Scott and we have time for two
more questions our next question your
examples of new technologies indicate
that they actually can be democracized
meaning made accessible for a broader
range of users can you elaborate a bit
more on what trend and what potential
you observed here
that's a very good question
um
so many of the Advanced Imaging tools
have emphasized Advanced and not the not
the uh Imaging side enough and it
it has sometimes seemed that the
equipment has become very challenging to
use one of the things that we've been
trying to do within the Imaging Center
at USC and also in our collaboration
with microscope companies is try to make
these microscopes so that they can
perform at a high level without having
to have as I was jokingly saying earlier
two physicists hanging over your
shoulder adjusting things
um
I think that uh there are two components
to making that democratization work one
is making the instrument itself so that
it's easy to operate at near Cutting
Edge performance
um without uh an advanced degree and in
imaging or Applied Physics or something
of that sort it might be for that extra
little bit at the end that you need to
the the specialized training but what
we're trying to do is give comp you know
performance that's way better than good
enough in a setting where there's uh
where the instrumentation is a help
rather than a hindrance
the other POS the other important thing
is having protocols for the use of that
equipment that are generalizable that
it's possible within your figure Legend
to as I mentioned earlier put the
protocol and and be able to almost uh
distribute to others the set of tools
and the set of parameters that were used
and I'm I'm very encouraged in our
recent Publications that the journals
have worked with us on that uh one of
our
projects with Carl kesselman and Don
Arnold and others here at USC we were
able to put a digital object identifiers
in the figure legends that take people
to the details of the protocols so that
it's not uh something where you have to
be an expert to interpret what was said
or what was implied in making the
experiment work
I think the equipment manufacturers have
been doing a great job too in making
these instruments much more
user-friendly rather than performance
only oriented some of the early Scopes
were much more like trying to drive in
an open go cart you can go really fast
but I wouldn't want to uh to carry the
family in it and right now I think the
microscopes are getting to be like very
high performance family sedans or
something of that sort
thank you Scott we have one final
question I'm very interested in Muse is
that an establish as is established as
commercial kit would be or does that
involve the Miracles of a 10-year
trained technician
that's almost the same question as the
last one but in a very different area
and
um the the questioner is right that many
of these technologies have been painful
and
um and recently HCR reagents are now
possible to to purchase from a company
from Niles Pierce and his colleagues
called molecular instruments The Muse
reagents are uh are taking a look are
more uh they're newer so they're um
they're more early in their design
trajectory and all but there is a a
group in Switzerland that's been
developing it under the leadership of
Simon Restrepo and he and a startup
company there have been working with
users generating kits that others can
can use and have had very nice results
in even a couple Publications coming out
using them
um the rapid adoption that I've seen
from others uh of the Muse technology
suggests that it doesn't require the
10-year expert and it doesn't require
the double secret protocol that isn't
written down to make it work we've all
been through those protocols and what
we're enjoying is finding something that
can work more robustly and can be handed
to a new user in the lab and get the
results and and so far it looks like
like Muse is passing that test
Scott I want to thank you for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go I definitely want to
thank labroots and our sponsor Leica
Microsystems for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go I
want to thank all of our audience
members for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab route to
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we can we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone thank
you Scott and everyone bye-bye
thank you bye now